[Music]
hello everyone
so in this part of the lecture on 2d
elasticity
we are going to introduce uh an entirely
new topic
uh on the air stress function now this
is a very classical technique which is
widely widely used
uh in all of dude elasticity uh
it has been used for more than 100 years
now
and it still remains extremely useful
now
as we were discussing in the first part
of the lecture on 2d elasticity
uh our studies here can be broadly
classified into
uh problems which fall under the purview
of
the plane stress type and those under
the
plane strain type now this eddy stress
function
uh approach of solving these problems uh
can again be applied to both these uh
the plane stress type and the plane
strain type of problems
uh and if we understand one of this the
other is
absolutely the same okay with some
differences in the
algebra so what we'll do is uh we'll
study the application of the error
stress function
in the plane stress approach so
for clean stress problems
now what we are going to start out with
is the stress equilibrium equations
and uh
because we are considering plane stress
what we have
is uh sigma
xz is equal to sigma yz
is equal to sigma zz equal to zero
for the plane stress problems and
therefore uh
if we consider the stress equilibrium
equations
which were introduced uh in the chapter
on stress
so for the stress equilibrium equations
we have
del sigma xx del x
plus del sigma x
y del y
is equal to zero now note here that i
have not written the contribution from
the body for stem so that is an implicit
assumption here
it is not to say that the area stress
function cannot be applied
for those problems which involve the
body force term
it can be but we are not doing that
but just as a side remark here
if we have to use the edu stress
function for problems involving the body
stress
then those body stresses must be of the
conservative nature
okay only then we can use the any stress
function approach but in order to
keep the algebra simple we are not going
to you
uh we are going to drop the body stress
term
okay so the next equation that we have
from the stress equilibrium
is del sigma xy del x plus del sigma
yy del y is equal to 0
and note that the third equation the z
component
of the stress equilibrium equations
involve the sigma
xz the sigma y z and the sigma zz so
they
do not come into the picture okay that
is identically a zero equal to zero form
furthermore you note that uh the sigma
xx
the sigma xy and the sigma yy they are
all only dependent on x and y
they do not have any functional
dependence on z
now our first requirement when we solve
a 2d elasticity problem or any
elasticity problem for that matter is
that
the stress equilibrium equations must be
satisfied because these
basically follow from the requirement of
satisfying the
linear momentum balance as we
as we studied in the chapter on stress
so it is absolutely essential
that these equations must be satisfied
okay
this is the basic requirement and
this is the starting point which
motivates our our introduction of the
airstress function so what do we do
actually so where is the where is the
new thing involved
well the new thing is like this that
because our requirement is that
these stress equilibrium equations must
be satisfied
so we try to find a situation
or we try to find a mathematical
method such that no matter
what we do no matter what we do
subsequently
these things necessarily will be
satisfied
so uh what i'm trying to motivate here
is that
perhaps or is it try to think of it like
this
that is it perhaps possible to find
a very general form of the sigma xx
and the sigma xy which also appears in
the second equation here
as well as the sigma yy such that these
two equations
will be identically satisfied okay
so when i say this it is with the
it is in the same spirit of asking the
question
which was uh which was uh which was
discussed in fluid mechanics
so let me just draw this quick write
this quickly in the
rough column here that under the
condition
of an incompressible fluid we had the
condition
that delta dot v is equal to zero
back in speed mechanics okay so
uh for a two dimensional situation what
we had
was l v x del x plus
del v y del y is equal to 0
where v x and v y are the x component
and the y components of the
velocity fields and note that v x and v
y
are themselves dependent only on x and y
much in the same way that the stress
fields
here are dependent only on x and y
now one approach which was used
to to ensure that this incompressibility
condition
would be always always satisfied was to
use
something called the stream function all
right
so back in fluid mechanics what we said
was that if vx
is set equal to something like del psi
del y
and v y is set
to minus del
psi del x then
automatically this particular forms
these these two particular forms they
ensure that this incompressibility
condition
is satisfied always so we don't have to
separately worry about satisfying this
incompressibility condition when we are
solving for the vx and vy
okay if they are of this form this is
always satisfied so
uh so exactly in that same spirit let me
come back here
and ask this question again that what
could possible
what could be the possible forms of
sigma xx sigma xy and sigma yy
such that these two stress equilibrium
conditions
uh are are identically always satisfied
okay so people have thought about this
thing and they have very cleverly
come up with a nice solution that if
so these are
always satisfied
if sigma x x
is taken to be of the form
del square phi del y square
sigma y y is taken to be of the form
del squared phi del x
square and sigma x y
is taken to view of the form minus del
square phi
del x del y and you can check for
yourself
if you substitute the expression for
sigma xx
in terms of this phi here then
you will get del square phi del x del y
square
and if you substitute the expression of
sigma x y here
then again you will get uh minus
del square pi del x del y square so
overall this thing becomes identically
equal to zero
similar is the case with this second
equation when we substitute the
expression for
this sigma yy in this in terms of this
phi
and it is this phi which is called
the airy stress function
okay named after uh
a mathematician uh from the united
kingdom
uh from the 19th century uh his name was
aries so in his honor it is is called
the area stress function
however
we have to be a little bit careful now
so
looking at these it may give us the
impression
that because we have
managed to identically satisfy this all
important stress equilibrium equations
then perhaps uh our problem is
solved for always okay so it is perhaps
magically solved for obvious we don't
have to worry about anything else
but that is not quite true okay so we
have to be a little bit careful here
so let me go to the next page and
uh and discuss these very important
things
okay it's a very very subtle thing but
extremely important and must never ever
be
neglected so the first thing that we
note is that
okay so let me write it down that
does this mean
that our
problem is magically solved
without having to think about anything
else
the answer is certainly no our problem
is not magically solved
okay so uh the first thing that we have
to be careful about
is that uh just because we have managed
to find
some clever forms for the sigma x6 sigma
yy and the sigma xy
uh which satisfy the stress equilibrium
equations it does not mean
that for a particular physical problem
the boundary conditions are
automatically satisfied okay
so we still have to worry about the
boundary conditions
the boundary conditions must be properly
considered
specific to the particular problem that
we are
tackling and next
very very importantly and this is where
we need to go back
to the concepts that we learned in the
kinematics chapter
we are obtaining certain forms for sigma
xx
sigma xy and sigma yy
all right now suppose we are dealing
with the simplest of materials uh
like uh like a linear
elastic isotropic material and using the
constitutive relation
we managed to find out correspondingly
the epsilon xx the epsilon xy
and the epsilon yy
now see this is exactly the kind of
situation which was discussed
in the under the topic of compatibility
so
here you note that if we do not respect
anything else
if we do not consider anything else and
if we just start
by arbitrarily using some area stress
function
pi okay and rely
on the apparent magic of uh
of having satisfied the stress
equilibrium equations
then it may be very well possible
that the strain fields that we end up
with
they may not be compatible okay so there
is
the danger
that these strains
may not be compatible okay this is very
important
you may not be compatible means that we
may not
end up with nice consistent uh
single valued uh displacement fees okay
so uh it is extremely extremely
important
to conclude from here that
this is our conclusion that
arbitrary choices
of the air stress function
are not allowed
this is extremely extremely important
point to note
we cannot arbitrarily choose this phi is
relying on the fact that they are
satisfying that the stress equilibrium
equations are being satisfied
so what do we do so in our entire
formulation
when we approach a particular elasticity
problem using the stress function
approach
then we must must be very careful about
respecting
the compatibility equations okay
so the information
from the compatibility equations
the information from the compatibility
equations must be embedded
[Music]
somehow must be embedded
within the mathematical formulation
of the stress function approach
okay this is a must
now uh in my experience
uh what i have noticed is that uh if i
lay out the entire formulation in front
of the students
sometimes at the third year level they
they face some difficulty
in simultaneously falling through the
algebra as well as getting a bird's eye
view
of what really is going on so at least
for this
uh pre-recorded video uh what i will do
is
i will i will lay out the story
what needs to be done and what we get
and
leave out the algebra part which can get
a little bit
involved not too much though
but it still gets a little bit involved
and leave that out to the
typeset notes which you can refer later
in a leisurely fashion okay so what
next what i will do is just lay out
the important steps so we have seen that
we need to respect the compatibility
equations
now back in the problem sheet uh
on kinematics uh you had you had
obtained
the various compatibility equations and
it turns out that for
the 2d elasticity case especially
within the purview of the plane strain
plane stress case
uh it is enough for us to consider the
the first of the compatibility equations
which is uh del square
epsilon x x del y square
plus del square epsilon y y
del x square
is equal to twice del square
epsilon x y del x del y
okay so we are not going to follow
through the
involved steps here i just want to
mention here that
uh this expression of epsilon x x and
epsilon y y and epsilon x y
uh for these uh these are converted in
terms
of the stresses okay using the
constitutive relations
and then using the constituted relations
that pertain
specifically to the plain stress case
and then
they are put in a more convenient
fashion
by let me just write it down here
so what we embed in here is the
information
from the constitutive relations
so that the strains
are expressed in terms of the stresses
furthermore
the information from the
from the stress equilibrium equations
are also
embedded here okay because you
understand
that once the constitutive relations are
used
they get expressed in terms of the
stresses and then we can
do a little bit of algebraic
manipulation to utilize
the two stress equilibrium equations
also
finally what we get as a result of all
of this
is all
all of this
will finally give us an equation which
uh which looks like this
so you can find the entire process
of of these things that substituting the
cultured relations as well as the
utilizing the stress equilibrium
equations in order to arrive
at this equation in the typeset nodes
please note that these this is on the
laplacian operator
okay so uh
this one is the laplacian operator which
you are
familiar from your first year
mathematics
and note that this laplacian operator
operates
on the sigma xx as well as on the sigma
yy
now let us not forget
that all of this is being done to
utilize the uh the clever
the clever solution afforded to us by
the
adistress function so as one last step
what we can do is to substitute the
expressions of sigma xx
and sigma yy as we had presented in an
earlier page
so let me just refer to that quickly
here
in this earlier page we have seen that
sigma xx is del square phi del y square
and sigma yy is del square pi del x
square
so i'm going to utilize that here so
that
our equation takes on
a very nice form
like this
you note that this can be further
put in an even even nicer form
in this fashion
where this laplacian operator operates
in turn on another laplacian operator
because i take this thing common and
finally this
entire double operation of the laplacian
it acts on this phi
so overall what why what i have is
that the laplacian operator square of
that
operating on phi so overall what i have
is del uh to the power 4
pi is equal to 0 okay so this is the
equation
which is of concern which is of primary
concern
in our area stress function approach and
just to
expand it out
because this is so very important we can
note that
if we carry out the the laplacian
operator
operating on itself the the laplacian
square
where what we what will obtain is
this particular form can write the pi
here
because i am expanding it out in full
okay so this is the equation that we
need to solve
in our
in our ad stress function approach
all right now please note
uh that
although it may seem to us that we have
considerably simplified our problem and
we have actually
and the greatest simplification is that
earlier
we were dealing with these various
unknown variables
sigma xx sigma xy sigma yy
in place of those we have now reduced
our
unknown variables to just one thing
which is this unknown
pi but in the process of doing that
we have uh we have ended up
with a slightly with a with a slightly
higher degree of complexity so to speak
in terms
of having an equation which is no longer
first order
or second order rather it is of order
four
okay so this differential equation is of
order for us and we have to deal with it
okay so uh in the
next part of the lecture what we are
going to discuss is
uh some ways which we can adopt to
to solve these things and the things
that we need to be careful about
all right thank you very much